CRISPR is the adaptive immune system in
bacteria that has the ability to grant viral
resistance.
How does it work? When a phage comes in and injects its
DNA into the host,
the CRISPR-Cas machinery,
which is always on, surveilling the cell, ready and on
the lookout for invasive DNA elements,
is going to recognize this invasive piece of DNA, latch on
to it,
scan through that DNA molecule for a piece of DNA that it has high
affinity for in terms of binding and recognizing and targeting, and through a copy
and paste mechanism,
it's going to take a small piece of that DNA, about 30 nucleotides, and insert it
into the CRISPR array as a new spacer,
essentially vaccinating the bacterium by capturing
genetically a piece of the invasive DNA.
Once the cell is vaccinated,
the way it works is the repeats, spacers, repeats CRISPR array is transcribed,
using RNA polymerase, into CRISPR RNAs,
a collection of small RNAs that each contain the genetic
information from one vaccination event.
So the repeat, spacer, repeat, spacer, repeat, spacer, repeat unit is all transcribed as one
long piece of RNA and that long piece of RNA is chopped
within each repeat to generate a collection of
immune elements that each contain the information from one vaccination event.
So each contains the information from one genetic invader.
And they're like little fingers that can latch on a piece of DNA,
one at a time, to recognize it and target it by sequence specificity. And all
those small pieces of RNA that are floating in the cell guide
an endonuclease,
called Cas9, that can come in and then latch on
to that target DNA,
using a sequence motif that it particularly likes and has very high biochemical affinity
for.
And then this molecular scissor right here,
this Cas9 scalpel,
is going to cut the DNA.
People underappreciate how smart, from a genetic standpoint,
bacteria are. CRISPR is an extremely sophisticated system
that is complex genetically,
mechanically,
biochemically,
it's very fast,
very protective,
it's very harmful to the phage. For CRISPR to overcome
a phage attack is this beautiful,
amazing piece of molecular machinery that will strategically target it,
cleave it, eradicate it,
and send it back home.